[Music]
in celebrity Feud news submitted by
Peter Phan Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman did a hilarious marketing
campaign together do you guys know about
their feud they have a few they have a
it's like a Deadpool vs. Wolverine thing
right
oh really a real feud or just like a
made-up because of Ryan vs. Hugh for you
to like will you've laid it out in the
[ __ ] whole thing yeah and yes it's
all started yeah they're fine they're
buds and [ __ ] so doing a social media
WWE thing anyway so they both teamed up
they they did a fake like truce or
whatever like trying to say okay we're
not gonna feed anymore
and they've decided to both make ads for
each other's companies so this is both
of the N so you know and I'll stop
talking so you're not suffering anymore
get a cup of coffee be a superhero
cuz laughing man beans are born with a
special power sure it's the best-tasting
coffee in the market yeah it awakens
your senses with unbelievable flavor but
it also lifts up communities around the
world in the form of housing and
scholarships and who could be behind
such a heroic company
you guessed it
hugh jackman the loving and caring man
who created laughing man is that a real
company yeah Hugh Jackman's company
though so he actually has a coffee
company yeah wow man that was really
that's really what the [ __ ] he looks so
different really cost a million dollars
um I I'm not quite ready to show my name
admin let's just cut for sake oh no it's
not almost finished just some color
correcting your assets just rolling Ryan
Reynolds is a complete and total jeans
pretty great time I'll have to try it
someday what he has a gene company I
don't know anyone geez gin I drink I
feel a big Jam like Jack yeah what do
you drink pal I just see you guys
drinking Hennessy and [ __ ] never seen
them drink Hennessy once
that's a cute way to like promote your
brands yeah you drink scotch on the
rocks
not one gin that worked that worked the
coffee didn't work but gin work I'll
drink the coffee I drink gin with coffee
in it you drink gin and juice a gin and
car well I thought it wasn't coffee with
a little bit of gin it was gin with some
yeah oh you drink straight whiskey
that's what you drink what you treat the
[ __ ] what does that [ __ ] you drink
straight wood you don't even [ __ ]
chase it down I'm like God yeah yeah
whatever what she jinx everything
Jameson holy [ __ ] TG motor oil - holy
[ __ ]
it doesn't matter she has a Texas throat
Oh David drinks Jameson's tree - he
loves whiskey oh you know what I was
thinking of it wasn't Jameson my men Oh
which one I was singing party 151 I
gather clear no no no the other one the
one that you make moonshine no you that
you drop red boy into Jack Daniels no
it's deeper Meister Jagermeister drinkin
he doesn't change is what's the label
it's a label you can watch Miss Piggy
Jagermeister sobs we drink Jager Meister
after the age of 25 you're a loser
yeah [ __ ] you why does it taste like
robitussin that's church that was church
it tastes like
robitussin yeah it's drank it was with
Red Bull it's pretty good a Red Bull hmm
coke one that sounds terrible it's Anya
and this was an ad for Jagermeister did
it work
this video is sponsored by a similar
idea
yeah did it work oh yeah this is going
around everywhere because everyone like
cute
so they have like a little friendly beef
all the time and then they support each
other's company that's pretty cool I
like that that's pretty fun you guys
need to make a beef with some other
youtubers to do that what I talk [ __ ] to
David all the time
who else could you mean like but it's
friendly fun right or leave me my real
like [ __ ] you which one like I should
have it was like Blanc foo very loosely
oh yeah that's just like they're all
[ __ ] his friend has friendly fun as it
gets like he's celebrating his wife's 20
him and his wife's anniversary and he's
he just made a little bit about it like
it's it's not serious [ __ ] yeah I wish
Wong foo was more hardcore like they are
in real [ __ ] yeah you do see in the
video in the videos they wouldn't even
hit hard like that I want them to though
cuz Phil actually is a big bully
they're nice guys he says Emma what the
ER calls me that
yeah he he calls me [ __ ] dirty [ __ ]
boy and I'm like but you're the one
that's Chinese
videos gonna come out and he's gonna
[ __ ] call you be like Joe take that
video down what the yeah
I'm just gonna promote your new your new
calendar your new t-shirt company yeah
she's nice gonna lose this sponsorship
with hefty trash cans does he actually
use that word with a yarn no they're so
nice
no these these are they oh they don't
use it at all
they're like Wayne Brady on Dave
Chappelle remember back then is like he
thought that he was pretty chill but
really yeah that was the best who they
really are in your life
wait what are you guys how about the
Wayne Brady the Dave Chappelle sketch
yeah when he's like oh yeah yeah cuz you
know how like everyone thinks Wayne
Brady is so wholesome but then when he
came on Jay Dave Chappelle he was so
crazy like he was doing coke and like
drug dealing and yeah hit and runs and
[ __ ] yeah and then and then he went back
to his game show hosting gigs yeah he he
was trying to like save his street cred
a little bit but then the money I guess
all the money so good watch turn that
down you're stupid to turn that down I
remember like I haven't watched what do
you call it Oh
daytime TV bro you even watch some dudes
whose line is it anyway I can't believe
we just talked about it anything so so I
haven't watched it in a while right and
then I saw jus Carey and I was like
grandpa Carey what the [ __ ] happened
Time Warp no dude that was like 20 years
ago
I needs to be skinny now yeah whose line
was like literally 20 years ago oh yeah
[Music]
we weren't we talking about Hugh Jackman
ever maybe my brain got the know
watching this I was also thinking about
like how YouTube people's they construct
drama and then they play it out on the
world stage and I never did that and I
guess sad because we have so much talent
and we never did that for each other Oh
cuz we like chill happy vibes yeah but
it's even funnier when we [ __ ] around
and pretend that we hate each other but
I guess sad well people really take it
like me they think that I really hate
David they think you and I really beef
but we all do though geo don't destroy
the magic all right I [ __ ] hate you
yeah [ __ ] hate you too like how you
smile when you say that you're like a
[ __ ] hate you when I was a teenager
watch this local public access show and
they it was like it was it was pretty
weird and they had these two characters
on there who they did so V commercials
cuz they were sponsored by so V and so
they were always a sponsored by Sobe and
then they would do an ad where they're
like they're drinking so B then they
immediately spit it out and like sorry
it's not the Soviet just like those a
fly yeah yeah yeah so they were just
[ __ ] all over so B the whole [ __ ]
time and then it made me want so be as a
kid what happened to that drink that
[ __ ] green tea was so good I know so
what happened yeah me neither
it was like a fruit drink yo B it's a
glass bottle as like a little lizard
lizard' are used to like the pink one I
think maybe it was hella unhealthy and
if you were like oh you don't give a
[ __ ] about that welcome to America what
are you absolutely talking about there's
no rock stars and monsters and I call
this guy I don't know anyone else that
drinks rock star
Yuri time I go there and I see rock star
it's like a smaller section yeah and
then I'm like cool [ __ ] trash buys
this me
it fits the deal yeah well you just went
on the soapy website and things like
they're still around if I'm by monster
and it's 2 for 4 or I can buy three rock
stars for for your bet your ass I get
kiddie stones faster that way
that's what I heard hey we should all
make commercials for each other's
companies that'd be fun oh yeah let's
make a barbell commercial all right
actually tired yeah you won't work out
all right
come to Barbeau guys it's [ __ ]
awesome baby we're sorry yeah yeah you
like lifting weights it's like I met my
wife at barbell brigade you guys should
go to barbell brigade - yeah and then
she's like I [ __ ] hate you and you're
like it'll go viral man did you guys
ever consider hey I can't even finish
this sentence so funny but did you guys
ever consider doing like a local
commercial for like oh no you got to do
it as the business owners cuz you're the
business owners it's the fun I'd like a
[ __ ] furniture store
get on your piano tie a piano tie bar
every time it has to be extra bad yeah I
never have a music video in the middle
like barbell brigade and then get your
workout here some [ __ ] and then you need
to read if going Craigslist and find
like a five-year-old and like a
seven-year-old who can stand next to you
at the end of the commercial
yeah you already have tyka but you need
like two other kids so giving up have
your mom in the background like it's a
family run that's the best go see Barco
see Barco see Bart there you go NGO taka
[Music]